de là et mustang chevrolet ou encore
porsche pour les voitures mais aussi
triomphe indian harley davidson pour les
motos pour sa sixième édition motors en
sol s'est déroulée au château de
neuville à gambais c'est une réunion de
passionnés d'autos et de motos caractère
ça véhicules avec lesquels il ya une
relation émotionnelle qui s'instaure
parce que il évoque un acteur célèbre un
film célèbre l'enfance également à ses
12 ans ce passionné a eu un flash il a
vu une ford mustang sur le circuit de
linas montlhéry
aujourd'hui il est collectionneur ça
c'est une ford mustang de 2,66 qui a été
récupéré dans les années 80 dans une
dans une casse et qui était et qui a été
détruite en fait et on est passé au bon
moment on a pu récupérer loto ont eu
beaucoup de temps pour la pour la
restaurer mais au bout de deux trois ans
et demi de dur labeur on a quand même
réussi à faire quelque chose d'assez
sympathique 50 exposants étaient
présents pour le plaisir des mordus
d'autos et de motos anciennes
quand on est ici au motor and soul or
ça transpire la passion il ya des
véhicules de toutes les époques qui a
pratiquement sortent des musées pour là
ça fait plaisir de les voir rouler
plusieurs animations proposées sur place
à balad concert barbier mais aussi
concours de style où les participants
sabic dans le style vestimentaire de
l'année de leur véhicule à l'image de ce
propriétaire d'une delahaye 1935 venu
pour la sixième édition de moteurs
henson pour montrer ma voiture avoir
l'occasion de la faire rouler aussi et
peut-être dans un cadre prestigieux
la prochaine édition est déjà fixée elle
se tiendra le 5 et 6 septembre 2020